all right Thomas Roden Thomas said David
I know your first language is Spanish
but your English is good what language
are your thoughts in what about your
dreams my default internal monologue is
basically English at this point unless
I'm having conversations in Spanish but
when it's just me thinking to myself I'm
basically thinking in English I've been
going to school in English since I was
five years old uh so that that's
basically that now dreams are
interesting because I will have dreams
where people who would real-life only
speak English are speaking fluent
Spanish in the dreams and it's sort of
no big deal and within the context of
the dream it'sit's dis considered part
and parcel of what's going on and sort
of makes sense I also know people who
only speak Spanish I would have dreams I
remember where my grandparents who only
spoke Spanish in real life in dreams
would be per perfect uh unaccented
English with people and in the dream it
sort of seemed normal or whatever so I I
in terms of dreaming I'd say both
languages for sure I've had dreams where
you know might my French is okay I've
studied French for many many years and
in the dreams I'm speaking French
perfectly fluently and I understand
everything that's going on whatever I
don't know that the language that P I
know people who only speak English who
dream in different languages although
I'm sure if we actually heard what it
was that was representing the other
language in the dream it wouldn't make
any sense I think that that is sort of
less notable than the the question of
what language do you think in is a
really interesting one see I thought
that your guess was in terms of dreams
that if you were with your family
members or if you're in Argentina right
and you would be dreaming so speaking in
Spanish but it's interesting that um you
can just kind of make up languages and
still kind understand it for some people
most people assume that in in dreams
if one is bilingual that everybody
speaks the language that they speak in
real life period but as we know dreams
often don't really make any sense and
and that's not the case and certainly I
I would say both languages now I know
people who have told me they're
convinced that deep down they have
fluency in a language that when they are
awake they can't speak because they had
dreams were
they were speaking a different language
and they believe that deep down the
ability to speak other languages is
there and we've heard of people having
strokes or going into comas and coming
out and speaking other languages
fluently and it hasn't really been
explained that I've read although maybe
maybe there is an explanation it's not
exactly a topic I've looked too much
into this idea that there are foreign
languages fluent foreign languages deep
inside us somewhere I don't know what
the explanation is for that I think the
idea is because your understanding how
other people are speaking to you but
it's your own creation it's your own
dream so of course you understand what
they're saying interesting yeah no I
think that there's there's probably a
lot a lot to that thanks for the
questions send them in david at david
packing.com Twitter Facebook reddit
anywhere you want great bonus show today
david pakman.com slash membership is how
you sign up and get instant access to
the bonus show which is how this program
stays on the air and continues to grow
we do have the 2017 David Pakman show
calendars available it's a comic book
themed calendar and you can get these at
david pakman.com slash calendar 17 you
can buy just the calendar if you want it
autographed that is an option and if you
want the calendar for free you can get
it with your membership at david
pakman.com slash calendar 17